Jamie Foxx has been entertaining millions
for decades, but away from the spotlight,
his family members have kept drifting away.
This is the tragic true story of the man born
Eric Marlon Bishop.
Jamie Foxx's life was riddled with roadblocks
pretty much right from the start, as he was
abandoned by both of his parents when he was
just a baby.
But it wasn't a completely tragic origin story,
as he did have other people in his life to
look after him.
As he recalled to O, The Oprah Magazine in
2005,
"My grandparents adopted me when I was 7 months
old.
I was never short on the love of a mother
and father, though it came from an earlier
generation of family."
The woman that Foxx calls his grandmother,
Estelle Marie Talley, is actually not his
biological grandmother, but instead, the adoptive
mother of his mother.
While his parents left him behind, he couldn't
help but miss them and hold out hope for them to return.
As he recalled,
"[My mom] was so fly and good-looking.
We were country, but my mom was straight city.
She had the new hair, the gold earrings, the
Stingray Corvette."
However, Foxx had more mixed feelings about
his father.
As he put it,
"Why couldn't he drive 28 miles to check on
a son who passed a football more than 1,000 yards?
I think some of his absence has to do with
his being a Muslim.
He drew a line in the sand: 'I'm a Muslim,
and since you're not, I can't be your father.'"
Jamie Foxx always had ambitions to make it
big, but his original goals were a little
different, as the Texas-bred entertainer hoped
to one day play professional football.
Specifically, he wanted to be the quarterback
for the Dallas Cowboys.
And this wasn't a mere pipe dream, as he actually
showed plenty of promise on the field back in the day.
While playing on the football squad at Terrell
High School, Foxx became the first quarterback
to pass for more than 1,000 yards in the school's
entire history.
Ultimately, though, sports stardom just wasn't
in the cards, as he wasn't blessed with the
right physical dimensions to make it all the
way to the pros.
Nevertheless, Terrell High made sure that
his athletic legacy lived on and also named
their performing arts center after him.
"Terrell, baby."
While his football dreams didn't work out,
Jamie Foxx still had a bright future ahead
of him, which was clear when he attended the
United States International University in
San Diego on a music scholarship.
He was excited about finally leaving behind
the racial bigotry of rural Texas, and he
hoped that things would be different at college.
As he recalled to O, the Oprah Magazine,
"I'd come from a world where blacks and whites
were separated by the town's railroad tracks
[...] But at the university, there were people
from 81 different countries."
Reality soon came crashing down on him, though,
as Foxx learned that despite his new diverse
surroundings, his race was still going to
be a roadblock.
He was partially excluded from his college
music department because of his skin color.
As he revealed to People Magazine,
"They wouldn't let me go on the stage but
they would let me behind the curtain because
there weren't any African Americans in the
production.
So I would sing in the back, and I would just
sing the parts they needed me [for]."
In 2004, Jamie Foxx's grandmother Estelle
Marie Talley passed away at her home in Terrell, Texas.
All of her grandson's memories of her raising
him overwhelmed him in the wake of her death.
As he recalled to GQ,
"I remember those hands wipin' tears from
my face [...] Those hands had me stuck at the casket.
I was stuck.
I couldn't move."
Foxx shared a genuine, authentic bond with
his grandmother that he doesn't have with
too many other people.
As he put it,
"If you could go to heaven right now and say,
'Where is Estelle Talley?'
Do that interview.
Because that's who knows me.
Nobody else."
While Foxx was really shaken up at the time,
in the years since, he's looked back at his
experiences with his grandmother with nothing
but love.
In 2019, he celebrated her birthday on Instagram
with an old picture and a caption that read,
"My rock...
Miss u always"
"'Act like you got some sense' is what she
would tell me all the time."
While his grandmother's death was heartbreaking,
a glimmer of hope came out of it for Foxx,
as his father actually showed up at her funeral.
After years of absence, he was tentatively
testing the waters to rejoin the family.
As Foxx recalled to GQ, his dad asked him,
"Are you my son?
Are you not my son?
I wanna reconcile but I'm scared."
Foxx then opened his arms and told his father,
"You don't have to be scared.
It is what it is."
Alas, after the funeral, his father disappeared
yet again.
Still, he remains hopeful.
A decade after the funeral, Foxx told The
Sunday Times in 2014 that the door remains
open for his father, partly in hopes of settling
some of the questions that have plagued him
for years, like:
"What happened?
Where were you?
Were you stricken with something?
Could you not make it?"
While Foxx's biological dad was never around,
he was able to find a consistent father figure
in the form of his mother's second ex-husband,
George Dixon.
As Foxx recalled to GQ,
"My stepfather's into sports.
When I was running track, I'd always be looking
for my stepfather.
Sometimes he'd stand outside the fence and
say, 'C'mon, man!'
And I'd make it.
I'd make the high jump."
But in a tragic turn of events that seems
almost too cruel to be true, Foxx almost lost
his stepfather as well.
Dixon was sentenced to seven years of prison
on a drug charge, which was particularly hard
on Foxx.
He felt like this man whom he admired so much
had failed him, though he wasn't going to
just kick him to the curb.
So when he got out of prison, Foxx extended
an invitation.
As he recalled,
"I said, 'You are gonna live with me.'
I got his parole changed.
I said, 'I will save your life, because your
kids are something special."
"That father taught me everything.
Taught me how to throw a football, um, um,
basketball, taught me how to play tennis."
His stepfather isn't the only family member
that Jamie Foxx has taken in and forgiven.
As he revealed during a 2020 appearance on
The Graham Norton Show, his relationship with
his mother had improved to the point that
they'd been living together since 2008.
Foxx was thankful to have his mom back in
his life, but he also admitted that it wasn't
an immediate adjustment to wholesome mother-son
bonding.
The road to reconciliation can be rocky, and
there was a lot of his childhood that he still
needed to process.
As he explained to The Sunday Times in 2014,
"We're trying to learn about each other.
You realize certain things that you missed
when you were growing up, like, 'Oh, I do
that because of that.'"
Jamie Foxx has been open about his struggle
with substance abuse and its effect on his
overall health.
This has included drug-induced mental breaks
that were bad enough that his family had to
intervene.
As he recalled in an interview with HipHollywood,
"When that [was] happening, I was lucky enough
to have people like my sister, like my family,
say, 'Yo, you can't go out right now, because
you're talking crazy."
In 2005, Foxx was partying hard after being
nominated for an Academy Award for Ray.
Then one week before the Oscars, he got a
call from Oprah Winfrey, who stepped in to
set him straight.
"She says, all of this gallivanting and all
this kind of shit, that's not what you want to do."
Winfrey put together an informal intervention
that helped Foxx realize that he needed to
take a step back from his reckless lifestyle.
"You know, sometimes, in the Oscars, the characters
that they award, sometimes they're a little
fractured-"
"This is bigger than you."
"Yeah, it's way bigger."
On more than one occasion, Jamie Foxx has
ruffled a few feathers with tasteless comments
and controversial behavior.
For example, during a 2009 episode of his
radio show The Foxxhole, he said about Miley
Cyrus, who was 17 at the time,
"Make a sex tape and grow up [...] Get some
crack in your pipe [...] Catch chlamydia on
a bicycle seat."
Then in 2015, Foxx introduced Caitlyn Jenner
at the iHeartRadio Music Awards, which was
around the time that rumors had started to
leak about her gender transition.
Foxx commented during the ceremony,
"He's doing a his and her duet all by himself.
Look, I'm just busting your balls — while
I still can."
Foxx has also come under fire for defending
controversial rappers like Kanye West and
Chris Brown, as well as mocking deaf people,
and exhibiting cruel behavior on sets.
He's also even been accused of sexual assault,
a claim that he has denied.
Jamie Foxx was always close with his sister
Deondra Dixon.
She had Down syndrome, and he often served
as her caretaker.
When people asked him if she was too much
of a burden, he would emphatically say no.
As he told GQ in 2004,
"If I can't take care of my sister who has
Down syndrome, what will people think of me
sittin' up in Mr. Chow, drinking Dom Pérignon
and doing interviews with GQ?
[...] So, no, we won't have any of that."
In 2020, Foxx took to Instagram to share the
tragic news of Dixon's passing.
He posted several photos of the two of them
together along with a caption that read in part:
"My heart is shattered into a million pieces...
my beautiful loving sister Deondra has transitioned...
I say transitioned because she will always
be alive...
anyone who knew my sis... knew that she was
a bright light."
"What have you learned from Deondra?"
"Learned how to live."
For many years, Jamie Foxx's daughter Corinne
Foxx experienced debilitating pain and nausea
during her menstrual cycle.
She thought this was normal, as several doctors
brushed off her concerns.
As she explained to Today,
"There's a lot of medical gaslighting that
goes into this journey.
I think women of color, especially, are often
silenced or not believed when they come in
with symptoms."
Corinne was eventually diagnosed with stage
4 endometriosis, a condition in which abnormal
tissue grows outside the uterus, causing extreme
discomfort.
She even had to undergo surgery in 2018 because
the pain was so debilitating.
She then became an ambassador for the Endometriosis
Foundation of America, as well as an executive
producer of Below the Belt, a documentary
raising awareness about the condition.
After the release of the film, her dad took
to Instagram to applaud his daughter for powering
through such a severe struggle and making
something positive out of it.
As he wrote,
"So proud of my daughter [...] Please check
out [...] Below The Belt... you will be blown
away by the courage the women possess in this
film."
Things took a very scary turn for Jamie Foxx
on April 12, 2023.
Corinne Foxx posted on social media that her
father had suffered a "medical complication,"
though she didn't provide any further explanation.
A source told CNN that Jamie was hospitalized
in Georgia, news that was met with an outpouring
of concern from friends and fans.
For weeks, the public was in the dark about
Foxx's condition.
But finally on May 12, he reassured everyone
that he was still alive and kicking and also
to say that he was very touched by everyone's
well wishes.
As he wrote on his Instagram story,
"Appreciate all the love!!!
Feeling blessed [...] see u all soon."
Later that year, Foxx returned to Instagram
with a video to explain why things were kept
under wraps, as he admitted,
"I just didn't want you to see me like that
[...] with tubes running out of me and trying
to figure out if I was going to make it through."
Foxx also cleared up some of the rumors by
saying that it wasn't as bad as some people
were speculating, although it was still pretty
harrowing.
As he elaborated,
"Some people said I was blind ... said I was
paralyzed.
I'm not paralyzed, but I [...] went to hell
and back."